stan when you were a child would you
color within the lines
i never called the wooden lines i was uh
the kind of oddball kid
i uh i enjoyed old movies from a very
young age
my parents were both very young when
they had us my sister and i i think my
mother was 22
and so because of that when i got to be
of an age where she could drop me
somewhere on a weekend
she would do that so she could have some
time to herself because she was still in
her twenties
and freaking with my grandparents and
when it wasn't it was some place
so maybe it was an arts and crafts thing
at the museum and then one weekend it
was the lido theater on pico
and they were showing a wc fields double
feature you can't cheat an honest man
and never give a sucker and even break
and i was alone with my popcorn for four
hours
and this black and white majesty was
happening on the screen
and if a kid at nine years old can have
an epiphany i had one
and from that point on i watched black
and white movies whenever i could and
usually was in the middle of the night
unbeknownst to my parents i would sneak
downstairs i would turn on channel 11 or
channel 13 and in between
used car commercials i would watch night
at the opera day at the races and then i
learned about laurel and hardy and so
then i moved on to them and then i moved
on
to humphrey bogart and spencer tracy and
so by the time i finished
middle school and high school i had a
journal where i would had kept notes of
all these black and white movies i had
seen
and in my junior year of high school i
trick-or-treated at groucho marx's house
and met groucho and then groucho invited
me
and six friends to come back and we
spent the day with him
which was glorious so no i definitely
did not
color inside the lines did he pass out
good candy by the way
well so the four of us went as as the
marx brothers and i went as groucho
and uh we had memorized bits from their
movies and what happened was we were on
our way to
the high school halloween party and
uh one of the dads said uh
you know i know where groucho is why
don't we stop you'll tell your friends
that you trick or treat it at grouch's
house when you get to the party
and we went okay and never figuring we'd
ever see him and so they drove all the
way up to the top of truesdale and
beverly hills and
we rang the bell and wait wait wait and
then all of a sudden we hear yes
and we go trick-or-treat by the way
houses up there were you know miles
apart so nobody was trick-or-treating
ever so that's these big giant white
doors open and it was like valhalla
because it was an all-white
interior very modern and the front of
the
house went to all the way to the back of
the house and the back of the house was
a white wall
with the sketch of groucho from an even
groucho so there was no doubt where you
were
and so she goes oh lord she sees us
oh lord and she goes i gotta go get
something for you to have so she departs
so now the four of us are standing in
this little glow of the light
in the portico and we're waiting for her
to come back and
groucho's partner girlfriend whatever
aaron fleming crossed from one side of
the house to the other looked down
and saw us this community of marx
brothers
and she says groucho you got to come see
this
and of course he came from the last room
in the house
and he starts coming towards us and it
wasn't until he got about halfway down
the hall it dawned on me that
i was him like we had been the marx
brothers as a unit but
as he got to me i realized i was groucho
and i look around and my friends have
bailed
they are too scared they're off in the
shadows now so now i'm standing right in
this
glow and he's coming at me and i i can
literally see my heart
beating out of my white shirt and i'm
holding my
little plastic cigar and my hand is
shaking and he finally gets to the door
and his beret and his cardigan sweater
and he looks at me and he's waiting for
me to say something
and in my very best 15 year old groucho
i say
well looks like i'm looking in the
mirror and groucho returned
by saying no you're much uglier and i
could die right then because i've been
insulted by groucho marx
so that's pretty much how it went and
then my friends returned and
my friend john who played harpo and i
did
two scenes from coconuts and day at the
races he was delighted and
and then went on his way and then merv
griffin
interviewed him about six months later
and he told the story on the merv
griffin show which made us of course
so giggly happy and then we had the we
called and said thank you and he said
would you like to come up to the house
and spend some time
and so we did and uh that's the photo
and that's the autograph and
yeah wow yeah
and it was just it was just sort of
almost on a dare that you were going it
was all it was never planned it was all
magical it was you know in hilariously
in the 1970s the city of beverly hills
had a
private phone book that was only
delivered to people that lived there and
every resident of beverly hills was in
the book
you could unlist your phone number but
you could not unlist your address
that's how the star maps were made and
and of course
horrible things started to happen and
that was the end of that but at the time
we just opened the book and flipped to
groucho marx and it said where he was
living so we knew exactly where to go
thinking back to that experience and how
sort of this dare this sort yeah i mean
it wasn't planned
how much does that shape your career as
a producer
just taking risks like that or oh
there's i don't know that that shaped my
career any other more than
i felt like there was kismet that had
happened and that
how could i not pursue a career
having had this incredible moment with
groucho marx and
i mean i thought it was there was
something that had happened magically
that i had to pursue
and i look i entered college as a
pre-med
flunked out of organic chemistry on my
first semester of my first year and
that was the end of that and so by the
end of my
four years i on a lark i applied to the
american film institute and got in
and then started in a mail room so my
career has always sort of been shaped by
not necessarily the path that anyone
else expected me to take
um you know i come out of afi thinking
i'm going to be a
producer of film instantly
and then i end up not being able to get
a job for six months and starting in the
mail room and the mailroom was for a
television company
and that just sent my trajectory of my
career towards television
and so i'm eventually producing
television movies became
what was right for me but it wasn't a
choice i didn't i
i have so far outlived my dreams
that little kid who was nine years old
who was sneaking downstairs to watch
laurel and hardy imagined himself in the
movie business but
doing something you know getting to be
on a set or being a sound man or a
cameraman but the idea that i would be a
producer and
have my own company and produce my own
movies and travel all over the world to
make movies and win an emmy and golden
globe all that none of that was ever in
the
in my imagination i've gone far past
what i ever imagined would happen for me
and that's my dad standing in the
background who drove us
and that's groucho that's unbelievable
and he had just won the honorary oscar
like two months before
wow that's so cool i was so
and because the five of us really knew
the marks brothers so well
we asked them like we margaret dumont
was always his foil
and we asked him i don't know if you
know what that is but margaret dumont
was in all of his movies and was sort of
the straight woman
oh she was like the mrs rittenhouse she
was always the woman
in the highfalutin job that they would
poke fun at
sure because most of their movies
through darts at the
privileged class and so groucho was
always the lead that would
be approached by this you know woman of
ayers
and it was always played by margaret
dumont in every movie and she goes back
to
when they were on uh vaudeville so she
was she was a foil for them
early on and so of course i said why was
she
so good at keeping i don't know how she
kept a straight face
in that and with the chaos around her
and with being with the funniest people
on the planet
and he said well it was very simple she
didn't get it
she never thought we were funny and
and i'm sure that was true i'm sure she
never thought they were funny i mean
there's no way you could keep a straight
face with groucho marx you know
hold me closer hold me closer if i
wasn't any closer i'd be behind you
you know how does she how does that line
happen and she's dead and
serious right well it's similar with
robin william morgan mindy so i don't
know how you would
yeah i wouldn't be able to yes but
having made the morgan mini movie uh i
did my research on that she
they the people on that set broke every
time oh they did oh yeah they would okay
reset and start again
yeah but margaret dumont never she never
did never nothing
now she was she had to be that good
because she came from theater
so there was no take two now in the
movies there were but he she had
become their foil they did this amazing
thing when they did
coconuts which is their first movie
which were going on for a big tangent
but when they did their first movie
they took that screenplay and they went
and acted it out
all over the country in venues all over
the country in fact
that's the crew in denver
that's the crew photo from when they
were performing the coconuts movie
lime out it wasn't a movie yet it was
they had never made a movie
they did it live in uh 35 cities and
every and the screenwriters were in the
audience and so if the jokes didn't work
they rewrote it for the next city
and if those jokes didn't work they were
so by the time they got to make the
movie for mgm
the jokes were all killer jokes because
they had performed them
it's like a stand-up getting ready to do
his hbo special well they're well
they'll do you know chris
rock will do it 150 times so that every
joke
works that's what they did now no
obviously nobody does that for a comedy
movie now
but that's why the coconuts has not was
not one bit one after another that
doesn't work
well and vaudeville was from what how
long to
well the teens and twenties okay it
stopped during the process
yeah i mean when people didn't have the
kind of money but also that when the
talkies became big then
vaudeville ceased to have as much
importance as you know as the
talkie movies kind of replaced
vaudeville sure okay